Reverend Ralph David Abernathy author of
the book and the walls came tumbling
down when did you first think that you
wanted to write your autobiography Oh
about four or five years ago I decided
that I would write my autobiography and
I have been working on it ever since
then not straight out but for a given
period I would write and I would leave
it you know and go back to it and come
back to it and so I wanted to write this
book happy about it yes I'm very very so
pleased
it is good good looking book and it is a
good book and it is more than 600 pages
of my life story I am the son of farmer
and I grew up in Linden Alabama Ringo
County in the heart of the black belt
and my grandfather and my grandmother
were born slaves and I just wanted to
tell my story and to show the youth of
America or the children of America that
you you may be locked in poverty and you
may have a difficult time surviving but
you can be what my dear friend writing
is a king often quoted if you can't be a
pine on the top of the hill you're
scrubbing the valley but being the best
little scrub by the side of the hill be
a bush if you can't be a tree and so you
can be something and somebody if you do
not lose your sense of Worth and dignity
and somebody that's when I start with
the last part of the book first the
epilogue and in there you described that
in 1980 you supported Ronald Reagan for
the presidency why'd you do that well I
did it for the simple reason first I
didn't believe President Carter could
lead the nation forward at that
particular juncture he is a good man but
I just didn't feel that you could run
the country as he had ran the state of
Georgia and he didn't have around him
the staff that was able to do that and
secondly I supported Ronald Reagan
because he was talking about jobs and
income and when I went on with that side
of my political life and and thirdly I
believed that young black people should
participate in both parties the
Republican Party has too long ignored us
and the Democrat Party has taken for us
for granted and so since all of my
colleagues in a ladder and
various places across the country were
supporting the Democratic Party I felt
that I should support Ronald Reagan and
so understood very very clearly that it
is a policy in politics according to
President Gerald Ford that you you
reward your friends but you punish your
enemies and so I thought I would launch
a job program and get help from mr.
Reagan and from the private sector as
well as the public sector you know the
Republicans have most of the money in
the country and I thought I would get
that type of help but he soon forgotten
what I had sought to do to him or I
cannot get through and one of the sting
was journalists just happened to have
been connected with my congregation and
I had to do grandmother's funeral and
she told me doctor having either what
you really should do to get to mr.
Reagan is get to mrs. Reagan and maybe
like that you can get through but it
Mason the people surrounded him I just
felt that they never let my calls
through and never gave me ample time to
explain fully the meaning of the
foundation for economic enterprises
development let's go back I didn't mean
it but I want to go back so that the
audience understands the context you
were asked to come and do public hold up
the hands and and an endorsed President
Reagan back during the 1980 campaign and
you did that do you hear the city in
which you did that and
Troy at Michigan and you flew up there
to do it and when you got there you had
a meeting with the president and then
you walked out and found it some of your
other friends were there with you yes I
found that other persons including Hosea
Williams farm staff member mine at the
Southern Christian Leadership Conference
had come to join me and in endorsing mr.
Regan but I had a private conference
with mrs. Reagan because I wanted to get
the guarantee from him that he wanted me
to endorse him and that he would be
accessible to me because I didn't want
to just be endorsing a man that I was
unable to talk to after you endorsed him
the elections over you tried to reach
President Reagan what happened well I
could not get in and further than ed
Meese and I went out to Palm Spring to
say President Gerald Ford and he was
most sympathetic and most kind and he
called the White House while I was there
and he there's an 81 right in the first
year yes and he said well hey means and
I want you to arrange a meeting with the
President and I want to Ralph happen
after has suffered greatly because my
colleagues didn't like that you know
they tried to dry up my resources and
everything and he said well I want him
to be able to talk to the president and
he said well I will arrange the meeting
and you can be assured I was in his
office at that particular time I had set
up the foundation for economic
enterprises development it was fully
contributions made to the organization
was fully tax-deductible and I had gone
through this ordeal of my friend Jane
Peterson had worked with me and and he
was the executive vice president of
organization and finally the meeting was
arranged and it was just about a
five-minute ten-minute meeting with the
president yes and was he interested
no mr. mee said told me that he was not
interested he must afford thought that
he could call to the White House some
millionaires about a hundred of them and
they could give the money that is was
necessary a hundred thousand dollars you
know each foot to the foundation and and
take care of one who's had suffered so
much for because I endorsed the
president and mr. mee said that he could
not call anybody to come to the White
House and and there were no private
sector funds available
and he told me that the public sector
write a proposal and we wrote a proposal
and finally we the Department of
Transportation pump to finally we
receive a small grant and we finally
received a small grant from the
Department of Labor and that is all that
we received and that was not enough to
sustain the foundation so the foundation
now is not has no address to receive
contributions and but I am working still
with Foundation and James Peterson is
working still with the foundation and
hopefully we will get it back operating
what you do in 1984 did you endorse
President Reagan for a second term no I
decided go with my friend just Lewis
Jackson Jesse Jackson I expressed the
hope and the dream of receiving the
nomination of the Democrats and so I
naturally used my former employee and my
friend and so I went to I went to guess
was somewhere in North Carolina and when
he announced his candidacy and I
supported him all the way he preached at
my church and spoke at the church and we
were able to give him more than $10,000
and an offering
for his candidacy and so that that was
that and we were proud to and he has
carried as closer as black people to the
White House than any other person Jesse
Jackson is a good man he's very very
articulate he has his faults and
failures and as all of us have them and
he has big eagle and but I don't know a
president United States that has not had
a big ego I guess it takes a big ego to
become the president in the epilogue
again you're right about the the
illnesses you had and you talk about the
strokes how many strokes have you had I
have had two small strokes never a
massive stroke and I have had brain
surgery one of the carotid arteries was
clogged and I went to Johns Hopkins
Hospital my wife took me there and I had
a carotid artery that that artery
supplies the blood flow to the brain
they are too and I became the fit the
first person to undergo that macroscopic
surgery and it takes about took about 12
hours and I cannot speak too clearly
because of it being called so
consequently when the anesthesiologist
came to me and gave me lessons and said
doctor breath they call me doctor a
doctor a when you wake up I want you to
wake up
talking and when we asked you to move
your right hand don't move your left
hand and we had you had to prove to us
that you understand when we asked who
was the President of the United States
we want you to say Ronald Reagan and so
consequently mr. Reagan did call me and
wish me success in everything and so
when I finished with the surgery and the
anesthesiologist called me dr. a wake up
I knew and I heard them the first time
but I knew that I would have to spend
the rest of my life from my meager earns
and savings paying them for such an
operation and so I just caused them some
anxiety they had to call me in the
second time doctor a wake up and I said
I love Jesus I love Jesus I love Jesus
and they said doctor hey don't say
another word
because you are running your blood
pressure off the cuff and what I was
thought to be did not happen
I was to have a black eye and I was to
have be kept in intensive care for five
or six days but the next morning I was
awakened and I had full breakfast
bacon and eggs and juice and coffee and
they said now we're not gonna get you
out of here because you you're doing
fine
and I called my wife over at the Hopkins
Ian and she says Oh Ralph why are you
and are you still picking and kicking in
and said I I'm back at in my room at
Johns Hopkins Hospital and she said I
cannot believe it
they said that you would be there four
or five days in intensive care
but God was good to me and God be the
glory he is do all the praise and people
across this nation had fasted and prayed
for me my family and when needed is a
very very lovely wife and I am proud
that she is the mother of my four lovely
children and she's a great woman and
she's a a woman of great intellect and
she is just I love her in the book we
have a picture here that the audience
will see of your family when was this
taken
oh that was taken I guess a couple of
years ago can you tell us who the who's
your daughter here oh that is Dawn's la
danza lay Abernathy is married now and
to George basslet and George Bosley is a
high school and not high school but
college schoolmate and who majored in
the movie industry also stars Leigh is
an actress she maintains her name a
Vanessa she's married to a young white
man
but she is she is dedicated to the
family she is the second of two
daughters this daughter right here that
is done delay and he said she is married
to a white man
yes would you tell us the story that you
tell him the book about the marriage
itself well it is just a very very
comical thing the church holds about
2500 people and the marriage was
scheduled for 11 o'clock and the it was
thought that George's mother had had a
heart attack
previous the previous evening and it
turned out that she just had some gas
pains or something like that but she was
in the hospital and George was to go by
and let her check him out and see his
tuxedo and and he neglected a junk will
do to call the church and be in contact
with me and and I thought that he might
have stood up my daughter and how late
was he yes he was about 45 minutes late
so he had a church full of 2,500 people
yes yes and they were waiting and father
Jim Nikki from Chicago Illinois is the
chaplain of the O'Hare Airport had been
invited to assist me and married my
daughter and I was Tamara but Satan they
he would was to assist me and I had him
go out and assure the people that George
was running late and finally George came
and what a relief it was for me all
right in this picture in addition to Don
delay you have another daughter
and let's see on the screen please there
we go who is this daughter this daughter
is Wunderland Wanda then is our oldest
daughter she lives in West Germany and
she is an opera singer she sang at the
wedding of Don delay she is not married
child recently but being able to see one
of my grandchildren before passing home
to the other side my new home she said
Oh daddy I'm not married and I said well
I would like to see some my
grandchildren and she said well what
about a surrogate a grandchild
and I said oh no no I want a real thing
I want a real abernathy we have more
children here in this picture your two
sons right here whereas the had his
corner the two 18 year old student at
Williams College in Massachusetts now
and Ralph David Abernathy the third he
is a member of the state legislature in
Georgia Ralph David Abernathy our guest
and the name of the book is and the
walls came tumbling down where did you
get the title well I just thought about
it and finally concluded that he's the
the old spiritual Joshua fit the Battle
of Jericho Jericho Jericho and the walls
came tumbling down did that you write
this yourself or did you have
no no I wrote it myself and naturally I
had editorial assistants and suggestions
and I had research person who checked
out dates for accuracy and who assisted
me in reading and grammar and spelling
words and so forth but it is my writings
my story my words and the walls came
tumbling down how did you write it did
you write on a typewriter longhand or a
computer or some sometimes I wrote it
from I own the legal pad in longhand and
I used to talk into a tape recording
machine and the secretary would lift it
from there and and I would used various
means no I can't cannot operate a
computer had I was not blessed with any
such skills and I had to deal with the
talking into a tape recorder or writing
it in longhand and I have my own type of
type of shorthand you know you you have
to write when you feel like writing
inspired to write you have to I have to
write my sermons like that so often my
wife said says to me you know Ralph if
you complete your sermon then then we
can go out you know and to a party
visit some friends but you don't write I
don't write like that I had to wait for
the moment of inspiration to come and
and I can work working working wicked
work long hours way unto the wee hours
of the morning often I set up all night
long did you write from total from
memory or had you kept notes over the
years I had kept notes over the years
and but mainly memory as acknowledged in
the introduction the Bible was written
by many and many inspired men of God but
the life of Jesus is recorded in what is
referred to as the Gospels Matthew Mark
Luke and John and they gave give the
life of the birth the the crucifixion
and the resurrection and the session of
our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ
but they all tell it in a different way
and I wrote it from my perspective and I
told it to the best of my ability and
memories sometimes fail but I had a
person to to check me on accurate dates
especially the New York Times
there are 638 pages including the index
in this book and as you all know three
pages out of this book have been the
focus of attention the night before
Martin Luther King was murdered are you
surprised that the only those three
pages have been the subject of all the
attention for this book I'm greatly
surprised
and disappointed why because to me it is
on the jealousy I didn't ask anybody if
I could write my autobiography it is my
story the story of my life and you would
believe it was the story of the life of
my dearest budding friend dr. Martin
Luther King jr. and so it is not his
story but it it is my story and the
second reason where I am surprised they
they took these four pages and created a
controversy and they sent me a tug
around and tried to get me to retrac
falsely accuse me of not having written
the book and and and demanding that I
withdraw the tell the publisher
repudiate this book and I said I cannot
do that and I went to Memphis on my face
so and and promoting the book and so
when I got there upon arrival at the
Peabody Hotel this young man from The
Commercial Appeal the only newspaper
anonymous in Memphis was there he was a
black young man and he said doctor have
an idea I need to see you and ask you
some questions and naturally I didn't
want to talk to him but he said it's
very rigid and
checked in and went up to the room and
came back to talk with him and he told
me the Associated Press had received a
telegram that has had been sent to me
from the Martin Luther King Center for
nonviolent social change and I thought
that was very very unfortunate because
the Martin Luther King Center for
nonviolent social change and he's being
very very violent and these people had
not come to see me at all only the
chairman of the board mr. Jesse Hill had
come to see me and he came not reaching
me keeping me standing all day that
Saturday and all day that Sunday and on
the Sunday he brought a dear friend of
mine who signed the telegram and he just
left on the message box of my wife's
telephone that I should look at under
the door because they had left a message
for me in the copy of the telegram that
I would be receiving and so I didn't it
was piercing and and strong and telling
me to repudiate it and I talked to dr.
Kilgore and took him the next morning
and dr. Kilgore was in
unique position because he had a love
enough love for me and my family
he and enough love for dr. King jr. and
his family and he loved and supported
both of us and I he was now in North
Carolina and they he hooked just he'll
hook me into dr. King doctor Kilgore and
we talked we talked we talked and we
prayed and we prayed and but we prayed
and I agreed to receive calls from the
wrong Bennett and from Bob Johnson the
editor of Jet magazine in Chicago and
the editor of Ebony magazine and since
they were learning in that field of
publication and next time I heard from
mr. Hill he was telling me I'm telling
my wife that that he had received the
message that I was supposed to answer
that I was supposed to give in response
to and their own Bennett never called me
Bob Johnson never called me and I didn't
dignify what they were trying to say to
me if they wanted to reach me my
telephone is listed there on the black
leader nationally black leader in the
country I have a listed telephone and
you can look in the telephone directory
and see the Reverend Ralph David
Abernathy and you can look in the
telephone book under the mayor Kay
Cosmetics section business section and
my wife telephone is listed mrs. Juanita
Odessa Jones Abernathy and so there is I
have always had the burning desire to be
accessible to the poor people of this
country and the food people of this land
why do you think your friends and there
are a lot of people that that are
well-known Jesse Jackson was in that I
assume signed that telegram and others
why do they feel so strongly about you
publishing what you say is the truth
about Martin Luther King well I don't
know you will have to ask them I cannot
answer that they help sales are you
selling more books because of all the
controversy no I don't know I have not
been in contact with the hop in row I
just heard that they have ordered some
more books but I don't know how the
sales of the books are going and whether
they are helping Haiti I just don't know
what do you think that of the way the
media has treated you the interviews
you've had have they been fair no a lot
of people ask me the same old questions
there's ago there it goes again the same
question over and over again and Bryant
Gumbel from NBC my brother who is my
hero March hard and long for him to have
the host to
today's show and he one week prior to my
appearance on NBC had come to Atlanta
and taped in an interview with me and
had not even mentioned anything about
Martin Luther King womanizing and
everything but he wanted to mean to come
to New York last Friday and I went to
New York and and I told him you know if
it wide come to Atlanta and asked me
nothing about these pages and nobody had
asked me anything about Martin Luther
King's womanizing and if they had been
shrewd most people that read a book and
buy a book especially in the black
community they stopped long before 435
pages they thought they don't read that
far and but they created a controversy
and so why why did you fly all the way
to New York to sit down with Bryant
Gumbel on The Today Show if did he tell
you what he was going to do that he
wanted to ask you about those pages
before you flew up there no he didn't
tell me that I was scheduled to go to
New York and sign books and promote the
book for hoppin rope and when I got
there just as I am in Washington today I
was invited to appear on your show and
so I was invited to appear on Phil
Donahue's
my wife and I were both on that show
and Ben hooks was on that show Roy Ennis
was on that show with us and the four of
us dealt with mr. Donahue
and the same same date and Hosea
Williams was invited and I understand he
he had called me the Judas of the
movement and Hosea Williams had always
supported me across the years and he had
brought fetid pieces of silver and like
Judas soul out Jesus for thirty pieces
of silver now the main thing Martin
Luther King wanted not to be a deity he
wanted to be just an ordinary man he
didn't want to be a saint are viewed as
a feint he was just a human being
capable of becoming and producing and
leading his people out of the wilderness
of segregation into the Promised Land
saying to me privately long before he
said it from the Memphis pulpit well I
may not get there but I have been to the
mountaintop
take my people all across this Jordan to
the land of Canaan and I want freedom
for all Americans and he freed many
white people and poor people who were
black American Indians the native people
of this country and he was just a
marvelous and fantastic leader and I am
surprised that they would Center on four
pages and I did ever say
that he had sex with anybody I said that
I when I was awakened he was coming out
of the room with this lady and maybe I
don't know what they did and me he never
told me he had sex with that lady and he
may have been in there discussing and
debating and trying to get her to go
along with the movement I don't know the
sanitation workers track I didn't say
that
and I didn't say later that when we
arrived at the motel of the Lorraine
Motel that he engaged in six I'll mail
it said that this Kentucky legislature
was there and when I discovered he was
in good hands I took off and went to be
because it was about 1:30 or 2:00
o'clock in the morning I didn't try to
dodge the issue I wanted to tell the
story where a mob would have validity
and not be thrown out by historians
because they would say he has not been
this he has been dishonest and not
talking about the life of Martin Luther
King and his fullest extent and so if he
lies about one thing looks over one side
of the picture the book is no good I
wanted him to be an honest and truthful
book and I told nothing but the truth so
help me God I am NOT a criminal
and I challenge anybody the
that I the things that I said was not
true in that book right after you you
this book was published and right after
the memphis appeal reporter and the AP
and all started writing about that that
four pages first thing we read was that
you'd had a couple strokes and he had
brain surgery and that something was
wrong and that's why you put it in here
and didn't quite know what you're doing
then after another series of stories we
read that Bernhard Lee who is written
about as the only other man with you
that night I believe before isn't that
correct is Bernhard leaves out here at
Lorton prison as a chaplain yes that's
right but then you hear Bernard Lee
being quoted as saying that you were
intoxicated that night well Bernard Lee
is quoted as saying that he is the
assistant pastor of the West Hunter
Street Baptist Church where you were yes
and I where I am today and Bernard Lee
has never assisted me as pastor of the
West under Street Baptist Church and so
he told an untruth I have never been a
drinking man I have never desired even
strong our Coca Cola is too strong for
me and it burns my throat and I have
never needed caffeine to wake me up I
have never been a smoker and I have
never been a coffee drinker he even if
his it is decaffeinated coffee and they
said that I have had two massive strokes
and I have had brain surgery but thanks
be to God you can ask me any question
about what happened in the movement I
was there and they were not there I was
there and I can give you an accurate
account of what happened
because I was there and I was alive and
I was awake and I have never been drunk
one last question on this particular
thing well why have they so why have
your former friends or you may call them
still your friends work so hard at
trying to discredit you what will be
after the dust clears on this what's the
effect of trying to discredit you well I
really don't know for my so-called
friends first they are so-called friends
because they didn't come to see me out
of the 25 or 30 people that signed that
telegram many of them I do not even know
and consequently only I guess two people
came to see me while I had these
so-called massive strokes now I am NOT
paralyzed a massive stroke believes in
any individual paralyzed or the mouth
disfigured or something like that but
thanks be to God I have all of my
thinking for faculties and my memory I
had talked slow and I am NOT the wear
and tear of the six and three years of
my life had its toll taken its toll on
me but I have been on this show you you
told me when I came in
yeah that yeah I came in here but the
understanding that I was talked to you
for 45 minutes and I'm you told me an
hour and I'm going an hour and I can go
to our
because I am an honest man and if you
expect me to talk to you an hour I will
talk to you two hours if necessary
because Jesus says when any man requires
of you to walk one mile with him walk
two miles with him and that meant in my
estimation the one mile is required but
when you used odd walking the second
mile he is embarrassed and he starts
loving you and being kind to you and
Jesus was a non violent personality but
Jesus became violent
on one occasion when he ran the people
out of the temple because they were
misusing his house and Martin Luther
King shared a woman across the bed the
next day because he lost his temple
people are just people even being the
model feeble beings and the Apostle Paul
had a thorn in his flesh which he spoke
about and I could call you list of
people I'm staying at the Jefferson
hotel but Thomas Jefferson had some had
made some mistakes also
the father of our nation George
Washington had made mistakes the slave
girls talked about his affairs and
Franklin Delano Roosevelt I I don't
propose to know and be able to talk
about these people but I do not speak of
him of them in this book but I do speak
of my friend Martin Luther King jr. and
he would want me to tell it like it is
and be honest and truthful and I am NOT
trying to hurt mrs. King because she
knows it is public knowledge J Edgar
Hoover had revealed Martin Luther King's
lifestyle and in the book I tell of
visits that I had made on his behalf and
I'm not trying to tell the children his
lovely children of anything about that
deity because I love those children and
they called me uncle Ralph and they
cited to me in the telegram that the
uncle Ralph I know would not do this yet
they do all kinds of things including
sending me mail to my house where they
invite not my wife to the birthday
celebration of Mahatma K Gandhi
they are just always trying to ignore
and rewrite history if you go to the
King Center
marches and demonstrations and if you go
to the Atlanta Hartsfield International
Airport you will see pictures of me and
Martin marching together and that
somebody has cropped me off they they
have decided that I am NOT going to feel
my rightful place in history and if they
have the power to blot out my having
been there by the side of Martin Luther
King they are willing they they have my
permission to try to block me out
because I came as Jesus came to preach
the gospel to the poor to heal the
brokenhearted the Freda captures to set
at liberty those are the bruised and
proclaim the acceptable year of the
world Lord I have been talking to you
all this time and have not even taken a
drink of water from this lovely cup that
I am gonna take him and put in a lofty
place signifying that I was here today
let me ask you and we're about out of
time
your chapter headings are Atlanta Albany
Birmingham st. Augustine Selma Chicago
Memphis Charleston Martin Luther King
jr. and then you have a chapter heading
Jesse Jackson now let me read to you the
last paragraph that you wrote about
Jesse Jackson in this in this chapter
yet I have supported him twice in his
bid for presidency ice assume that's
1984 1988 that's right and I suspect
that I will support him again if he
chooses to run over the years I've come
to love and admire Jesse in part
because he has matured into a great
leader in part because he has been so
supportive of me you go on to write
though in the book or you wrote before
that in the book about the night that
Martin Luther King was was killed and
the story that we have looked at many
times since then was Jesse Jackson there
and did he cradle Martin Luther King in
his arms and you talk about how you did
close your word to him and that Jesse
Jackson I've got the quotes here right
in front of me was nowhere around right
after the shot was fired how do you how
do we you know how much admiration is
there from Jesse Jackson to you and and
after this episode where he has
denounced you and and what you said here
do you think you're still supporting the
next time he runs for president
well dis Jackson is a good man and he
has shown amazing growth in his maturity
as we all he was young then but he did
not cradle Martin to King he was down in
the courtyard and his first reaction was
to call mrs. King and notify her that he
had been shot but I rushed to the side
of margin to King and I cradled him in
mom's and Bernard Lee I want you to ask
him didn't not I and he commit civil
disobedience and stay in the operating
room and the doctor came over and said
to me it would be an act of mercy if God
to him because he would be a vegetable
he would be paralysed from his neck down
and I want you to ask Jose Williams
where did Jesse Jackson get that blood
from the man that called me the Jews
and the man that who has supported me
all of these years and I have never done
anything but tried to tell the truth and
tried to be with Martin Luther King and
all of his efforts where while he was
alive and lived in resurrection city
right here in Washington DC and built
the the resurrection city and stayed in
the mood
trying to keep Martin Luther King's
dream alive of exposing poverty in this
nation what's your favorite chapter we
just have a minute left of all the
chapters Oh my favorite chapter is the
chapter little David the first chapter
in the book because I just love I just
love I'm my daddy upon birth when I was
delivered by my maternal grandmother
Ellen Bale he came home and made my name
little David and I regret the fact that
my sister later added Ralph because
Ralph does not have much meaning but I
loved the name David
I was a little David liked the goal like
goal I faced and I was able to do much
much to help Martin Luther King realize
his dream and mine dreams and the dreams
of all black people in this country our
guest for the last hour has been a Ralph
David Abernathy and this is the book and
the walls came tumbling down an
autobiography thank you for being with
us thank you so very very kindly